tony mélanger bonjour merci d'être
heures de direct à être ou sur arte
france alors le procès de julian assange
a donc repris hier à londres
il va durer environ trois semaines quel
regard portez-vous sur cette nouvelle
audience a le regard et ça pour moi
c'est un pour nous aussi la fédération
internationale des journalistes
c'est un acharnement judiciaire je veux
juste apporter une précision tout à
l'heure dans dans l'introduction il a
été défini comme un lanceur de l'ertt
pour la fédération internationale c'est
pas un lanceur d'alerté le vert assange
il est détenteur de la carte de presse
internationale et il est membre de notre
achilli en australie syndiqués en
australie est prononcé il a fait un
travail de journaliste comme l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs là la personne
que vous allez retrouver de taxi
internationale il a fait juste il a
juste montré et publié des informations
d'intérêt public et donc à partir de ce
moment là il a fait pour nous un travail
de journaliste
et dieu sait est comme son père le
rappelait aussi john shipton que j'ai
encore regardé sa manche la justice
anglaise s'honorerait d'annuler cette
volonté américaine dans tout à dos
l'administration américaine de vouloir
extradé un homme qui a tout simplement
fait que son métier est rendue publique
et les informations qui ne sont pas des
crimes là contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre dans un dossier et le précédent
d'être simplement des informations
d'intérêt public à la à former le public
c'était donc l'objectif de la mission de
diana sens je vous le dites vous-même
journalistes justement quel message on
verrait une extradition de tolède
assange vers les états unis vous avez
complètement raison c'est une question
là c'est la question primordiale de deux
de ses troisièmes aux auditions après
celle de février est toujours le message
ont tous parlé de fiction imaginons
qu'un journaliste français publie des
informations classées secret défense sur
l'arabie saoudite par exemple qui n'est
pas du tout évidemment un pays dont on
parle en ce moment
et l'arabie saudite il imaginerait que
ce sont des informations ans
alors un tout petit problème de liaison
en tout cas merci anthony bellanger vous
êtes toujours là oui oui je suis là oui
continuez je vous en prie on est juste
eu un petit problème de liaison
j'imaginais juste une fiction sur la
question de l'extradition
une fiction avec un journaliste français
par exemple qui va publier des
informations gênantes sur l'arabie
saoudite pays dont on parle assez peu en
ce moment et c'est ce journaliste de
passage dans un pays sous l'affluence
dans le golfe par exemple sous influence
de l'arabie saoudite pourrait tout
simplement est arrêté à la demande de
l'arabie saoudite dans la mesure où la
question de julian assange aurait fait
jurisprudence
ça c'est un cas très concrets ça veut
dire qu'on serait dans le cul dans la
culture du secret dans là dedans le dans
dans une dans une dans une dans un
journalisme qui ne serait qu entre les
mains de ceux qui ne peuvent pas avoir
l'information et qui peuvent la galère
la donner et c'est pour cette raison-là
que cette extradition elle est
extrêmement dangereuse pour la liberté
d'information
ça c'est un roman mais aussi pour tous
les journalistes est ce que justement
aujourd'hui cette liberté d'expression
est en danger absolument et c'est pour
cette raison-là des journalistes en
prison il est à peu près de 400 dans le
monde et la fédération internationale je
rappelle que la première organisation
mondiale
les soutiens et fait tout ce qui est en
son pouvoir pour les sortir la question
d'une récent g20 au delà une fois encore
on est au delà du principe on est on
veut pas en faire un saint ou pas en
faire un héros
cet homme-là s'il est extradé demain
mais comme vous le vôtre reportage le
disait très bien il y aura évidemment
des saturn qui seront qui seront
engagées en 2001 doral justice mais s'il
devait être extradé demain c'est toute
la profession qui serait inquiété par
par cette décision qui fera une fois
encore jurisprudence dans le monde alors
qu'une fois encore cet homme n'a fait
que révéler des crimes de guerre et des
informations d'intérêt public
donc oui ce serait une vraie catastrophe
et un recul comme rarement on en a connu
dans la profession
ces dernières années dernière question
monsieur bélanger est ce que la france
selon vous un rôle à jouer
justement dans le procès de julian
assange on pense évidemment à l'actuelle
garde des sceaux avec dupond-moretti qui
avait formulé une demande d'asile
politique lorsqu'il était l'avocat du
journaliste
une fois encore c'est tout à fait exact
et pour être honnête nous nous affilier
en france syndicat national des
journalistes notamment et nos confrères
de la liste des anciens candidats cgt
sont en train de travailler avec les
services de l'élysée pour retrouver une
voix qui sembleraient la meilleure pour
finale assange et qui montreraient
notamment au royaume uni et qu'il ya des
pays où la liberté d'expression et la
démocratie sont des aspects essentiels
dans la vie des citoyens
et effectivement le garde des sceaux
monsieur dupont moretti s'était engagé
il ya quelques mois avec nos confrères
de mediapart notamment pour faire en
sorte que julien un singe obtiennent
l'asile politique en france
on a demandé la même chose nous a à
bruxelles ça n'a pas été entendu mais on
a toute confiance et on a l'envié en a
grand espoir évidemment pour que le
gouvernement de monsieur castells et
puis tu le président de la république
lui-même mais ce mac on entendre ce
message et avec juste voir sens aux
ministres justice pour qu'il lui
explique un peu les tenants et les
aboutissants des dossiers sachant qu'il
faut encore les uns les autres au sein
de la fédération internationale où là on
a déjà expliqué toutes ces questions en
long et en large dans mon service de
l'église
merci beaucoup anthony bellanger d'avoir
réagi sur notre plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général de la
fédération internationale des
journalistes